il a pris le paddle vraiment
super au sérieux
depuis hier soir il est dans son match
ah ouais ouais ouais
le matin il va faire ses exercices dans
la piscine pour pour ces gens mais non
c'est c'est un autre Siri
alors on s'attend à un joueur un peu qui
fait la fête qui fait qui chambre tout
le monde sur le terrain mais on se sent
assez concentré il joue les coussins et
il joue du coup il sait tout faire
pour le coup l'évolution et assez
significative il a beaucoup progressé on
le voit sur sur son classement même
physiquement on sent qu'il s'est qui
sait aussi un petit peu un petit peu
affûté et voilà il a il a il a l'envie
il est complètement différent c'est pas
du tout le même on sent qu'il prend ça à
cœur et que c'est il aime vraiment ça
quoi parce que c'est pas évident de
toute manière je pense pas qu'il est le